[Music]
mcu boss kevin feige provided us with
two
exciting pieces of news about deadpool
this week feige announced in an
interview at the occasion of the one
division release on disney plus
that the third part similar to the
preceding ones will not cut back on fake
blood and brutality
in addition he confirms that deadpool 3
will again receive an
r rating and that they are currently
writing the script and the screenplay
together with
ryan reynolds many fans should be quite
relieved because in the past it was
often said
that there were no plans for deadpool in
the near future another good news for
all fans of the hilarious mercenary is
that deadpool will henceforth be part of
the
mcu this was previously not the case as
the franchise belonged to 20th century
fox before the disney takeover however
there is one small drop of bitterness
for impatient fans because feige
reiterated that the film will not be
made this year
this is primarily due to ron reynolds
busy schedule which is why release date
prior to 2023 seems
very unrealistic yet that's not the only
thing foggy had to say about the mcu
among other things he confirmed that he
expects another avengers movie to be
released in the future
that's not really surprising after all
marvel delivered the most successful
film of all time with avengers
and game nevertheless popular characters
like iron man and captain america will
of course have to be bit farewell
as others will follow in their footsteps
so what an upcoming avengers movie might
look like is still
up in the air we do hope to find out
more about phase 5 of the
mcu after the second season of the
umbrella academy ended with a great
twist
fans are now eagerly awaiting the new
characters in season 3.
a total of 7 new characters are going to
be introduced in the upcoming season
including justin cornwell as marcus
justin h min as
ben brittany altford as faye and many
others among the members of sparrow
academy there's also the floating cube
whose identity raised questions after
the season finale
by significantly altering the past the
group around luther hargreaves and co
created a new timeline
in which foster father sir reginald
hargreaves chose completely different
children for his academy and created
sparrow academy instead of umbrella
academy
it is not yet clear when exactly the
third season of the netflix series will
be released
but production will definitely start as
early as next month
after all the recent postponements of
theatrical releases it seems that we can
expect high
profile blockbusters on demand in the
near future and not just due to warner's
controversial streaming strategy as
variety reports the same is the case
with a sci-fi adventure
the tomorrow war featuring chris pratt
as amazon has shown great interest in
the 200 million
film and is nearing the conclusion of
negotiations
furthermore netflix and apple have also
apparently offered a deal but amazon
seems to have the lead
the story of the tomorrow war is about a
future world in which humanity is on the
brink of war with aliens
however things aren't quite looking good
for the earthlings so all
efforts are made to recruit legendary
soldiers from the past using time travel
technology the original cinema release
was planned for july 22nd 2021
unfortunately there is currently no
information about a potential streaming
release
we have known for quite some time that
amazon is producing a gigantic lords of
the ring series
what has been communicated very
cautiously since then however
is information concerning the story and
that despite the fact that filming has
already been underway since last fall
the onering.net has now published a bit
of information about the series
is well known that this story is set in
the second age of middle-earth
included in the report is talk of
unlikely heroes falling and rising
kingdoms and the greatest
villain ever to emerge from tolkien's
pen this refers as you can probably
guess
sauron further it is said that the
series will begin in a peaceful age
in which a cast of familia as well as
new characters will oppose the ever
increasing evil and embrace a huge world
around the misty mountains
the elf capital of london the kingdom of
numeron
along us with the furthest reaches of
the map thus assuming the information is
correct we are
indeed dealing with a gigantic story
about the prehistory of the
rings actress morphed clark might very
well be right in her claim that this
series can keep up with marvel in terms
of scope
at any rate all of us are already
looking forward to the upcoming amazon
series and are eagerly anticipating the
end of the year when the giant project
will be available
on amazon prime and that's it for this
week to find more movie news and the
latest trailers check
our brand new website kinochak.com or
easily leave us up on this channel to
get
everything new first
you